all right everybody say hello to the
guys that please don't destroy John
Higgins Martin herle and Ben
[Music]
[Applause]
Marshall
[Music]
at Christmas time at Christmas time it's
Perle oh my God you guys are so nice I
know they're lovely they're lovely so so
you you guys wrote for Miley's um New
Year's Eve show and Paris was on that we
did when she's saying stars are blind
and the place went crazy insane that was
a great show yeah yeah yeah it was so
cool yeah do you all like doing those
kind of events like writing for that no
but
it's yeah I mean it was totally we
definitely got PID for paychecks and
paychecks so
hardcast no it was awesome the coolest
part was getting to see people like
Paris perform it was amazing oh my God
you are so my favorite so
far oh my god do you what do you
remember about that that show did you
love that that was was it a surprise
thing I feel like I remember it being a
surprising nobody knew yes I was a
surprised and it was I was so nervous
because that was my first time doing
that and just to be out there with Miley
and CA and singing my song and them
singing it it was just so iconic yeah
and so Unforgettable thank I love when
artists come together to do something
like that's the coolest thing ever they
just the unexpected of it I love that
yeah I don't like doing it anymore
because I have kids cuz it's hard like
with kids um but you guys went out on
tour right with this what did you was it
fun did you like it it was amazing did
you do the bus thing and everything we
did the bus thing love the tour bus like
in the little coffin call them coffins
that's what we you sleep so well because
it's just it's like the the white noise
of the road and it's just like
completely blacked out this is what I
missed yeah it's awesome we feel like
rock star we really did somebody threw a
bra on stage one night congratulations
one one one person through a bra 30 city
tour one bra
yep and we handled it like Rockstar oh
definitely on Amazing
yeah you tried it on yeah what city I'm
curious do you remember the city I think
it was Portland okay I would expect that
in Portland they seem fun yeah yeah yep
so wait so you live together right we
used to you oh you don't anymore did y
all was that a CO thing is that when
that happened y all started it was
during Co yeah yeah and then a little
bit after too right on how did you like
being roommates did not okay okay well I
had a different answer but now I feel
one of you is I loved it oh I loved it
too yeah it was great it was an awesome
experience no we lived in like a tiny
apartment with two other guys uh for all
of Co so we couldn't really leave so I
think we just went kind of nuts like in
each other's space yeah and uh Martin
developed this thing called the system
oh do you want to talk about the system
I uh a little bit yeah um the system I
decided that I was going to figure out
the best way to eat food
um I wanted to figure out how to make
cooking would do the least amount of
work and spend the least amount of money
and eat every day so by the end of the
system Taco
Bell you would think but the system was
cheaper than Taco Bell the system was
for $5 a day I would eat all of my meals
I would go around to different delies in
Manhattan and find the cheapest half
pound of ham y um and each I can't
believe I'm talking about this I love
that you're talking about this this
feels like a weird dream yeah so wait
you just like make sandwiches gold from
paris's beautiful story about her baby
so I would eat $3
H it was uh there was an alpha numeric
uh sort of system oh I love that you're
elevating it with your vocabulary yeah
yeah yeah so for example a b3h okay
would refer to a b designation salad on
the third day of meal prep okay uh with
a ham sandwich meal prep for a sandwich
well the sandwich wasn't meal prep the
sandwich was made day up this is an
important aspect of the system the salad
is made four days in advance with
alternating uh pinto and black beans
that would be a and b salad what's your
favorite bean I would have to go with
black beans me too yeah I kind of hated
when there was an a salad week yeah yeah
yeah you're so awesome and so and so I
didn't love living with
Martin
wait wait so wait let's talk about the
new movie how is it let's talk about the
new movie movie movie I know I want to
talk about the movie what about the
movie tell them about the movie you want
to keep talking about the scors I want
to tell we could so we are also on
peacock peacock
peacock peacock yeah we made a movie
where it's basically like grownup
Goonies which wow I'm into that I've
heard that's your favorite movie right
yes so it's like us as like three loser
adults who think the best way to change
their lives is to go on a treasure hunt
and find treasure okay you're going to
think I'm really loser cuz my sister and
I actually have this
dream we're like no I'm not even kidding
my sister and I she's always been into
like treasure she's like I want to do
this at some point I'm like I don't even
know how you do that but we're going to
do it you got to go yeah well no segue
there we need another commercial break
please don't destroy the Treasure of
Foggy Mountain is streaming on peacock
and be sure to watch Saturday Night Live
Saturdays on NBC and peacock with all
episodes streaming on peacock we will be
right back
[Applause]
[Music]
people thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home